[Musique]
à sochaux la semaine a été lourde
les obsèques du jeune ouvrier jambes et
look une grande foule a suivi ont
rappelé la gravité des échauffourées qui
ont eu lieu aux usines peugeot après
l'occupation par les forces de police
deux morts 67 blessés dans la
métallurgie la persistance des poches de
grève s'est révélée dangereuse
le secteur de l'automobile en
particulier est demeuré sur le front
social
le point dur le point névralgique
[Musique]
oh
on
les échauffourées de flins avait fait
aussi une victime gilles taupin
l'étudiant noyer dont les obsèques se
sont déroulées à paris
[Musique]
au bout de sept nouvelles longues
semaines cependant on pouvait espérer
arriver à la détente avec la reprise du
travail aux usines renault considéré
généralement comme la clé du problème
[Musique]